this is what we were required they tell
us that a bees are diameter a P is any
cord you like and then they put in a
queue so that what what's it what's
special about caught a kook it's not
just any cord yeah very good it bisects
this angle here which is why I've
labeled them both as theatres you could
label them alphas or X's or whatever you
wanted okay and then the result they're
suggesting is and I really love this
when I do a circular geometry question I
don't know what the answer is
I could instruct the diagram and if I
fall in the steps it just magically
happens like is does it look like 90
degrees your diagram if you constructed
a good diagram it should look like a
right angle okay so we're trying to
prove that that guy I just need a T for
tangent is going to be 90 degrees so
what can we do people who've got the
solution have already made a
construction what construction did you
join oh look yeah you constructed a
radius and you sensing a common theme
here right when you don't know what to
do constructor radius OQ was the radius
that most people constructed once you've
got that because this line here is the
tangent at Q that you know OQ is going
to be perpendicular to this tangent at
it's a point of contact right okay so
that looks good now what else can you do
well in this triangle here where theater
is and you constructed this radius well
what kind of triangle is this its
isosceles so you've got AB a single over
here B theta does that make sense
okay we're always there we're so very
close where can you lead me from here is
anyone's just seen it a cutie that's
going to be the complement of 90 degrees
can you see that 90 minus theta because
oqt is another one of those right angles
and feeder is over here so 90 minus C
and then you're pretty much home aren't
you because look in this triangle a
cutie right I can say that theta plus 90
minus theta that's the egg
we just proved +8 EQ which is our
mystery angle that should be 180 degrees
so the theatres cancel like that Peter -
theta you can subtract 90 degrees from
both sides and there is the required
result which is really nice and fun okay
so as a way to conclude I actually want
to show you a website I really like it's
some you'll you already think I've
because I'm a math teacher because I am
but you'll be like wow you're even
wonder than I thought you were so this
is a website made by a math teacher and
it's called it's called math with bad
drawings because that is exactly what it
is you might have seen it before
anyway this post was actually written by
this guy like literally just a couple
days ago it's really new and it just
perfectly sums up what I hope you have
all gotten out of this course this some
blog post he wrote about is called the
state of being stuck so you met this guy
named Andrew Wiles has anyone heard of
that name before
probably not Adrian Wiles proved this
theorem um not this one we know what
this one is right this is Pythagoras
right what Andrew Wiles proved was that
if you take those powers and make them
not twos but threes or fours or five or
in fact any number bigger than two then
you will never ever ever no matter what
end you choose no matter what a B or C
you choose you will never find solutions
that are integers that are whole numbers
and this is a really famous theorem
because it was called for Mars Last
Theorem form how is this famous French
mathematician and he was like oh I
proved this but I don't have space to
write it in my margin here so you just
won't won't be able to find out this
stay done proved for centuries and then
Andrew Wiles came along and it took him
a decade basically to prove this now I
just want to show you one let me find
the spot no not that that
[Music]
no hold on is that no aha
here we go this is the picture I want
Shay okay so if there is one thing I
have taught you in this course I hope it
is when you are trying so a problem
right and you are stuck you're on a snag
you're like I'm not making progress okay
if you're not a mathematician you just
get angry and frustrating you're like
you flip the table you walk off because
you're like I can't I can't do it I give
up right
what makes mathematicians mathematicians
not that they're better with numbers or
they're quicker or more accurate but
they say okay well I'm stuck let me see
what else I can find
let me dig a little further that's what
this entire course has been about